e
okay we're going to go ahead and get
started on the hearing on Senate Bill
219 and I'd like to call on Senator
Murphy to introduce his bill good
morning Madam chair members of the
committee Senator Keith Murphy
presenting the towns of hookit gtown
Raymond Candia and Manchester's First
Ward um this bill is a taxpayer
transparency bill um I'm sure that being
an education committee you know better
than I uh the issue that this bill
attempts to address but in essence the
last two decades our cost per pupil has
increased
77% adjusting for inflation while our
teacher salaries are only up
1% in the same 20 year period our
non-teaching staff is up
80% the number of teachers is up only
23%
and yet our enrollment is down
11.2% so we're spending more than ever
to educate fewer
children so the bill in front of you
essentially says that the school board
every year School District
would produce
charts now I know that someone else has
handed out some copies for you to look
at but here's what one of those charts
would look like it lays out the cost per
pupil the average teacher
salary
and the
top y thank you forgive me I forgot the
prohibition there are copies in front of
you and the administrator salaries
so again this is for taxpayer
transparency it's so taxpayers can see
where the money is going in their
districts if you believe in taxpayer
transparency I believe that this is a
common sense bill
um um some may say well can't you dig
into the reports and find the
information and the answer would be yes
if taxpayers had three or four hours to
go dig the reports dig out the numbers
pull out an Excel spreadsheet and had
the the uh experience necessary to
produce those reports they could put the
formulas in and come out with the same
report which indicates exactly how easy
it is for somebody in the school
district school district office to
produce this makes it very very
straightforward and simple and taxpayers
have the right to know where their money
is going and that's all the bill does
and that conclud concludes my comments
if anyone has any questions I'm happy to
answer them are there any questions from
the
committee yes representative
Damon thank you madam chair thank you
for taking my question and please just
give me a sec so I can find what the
line is on
it
um or you tell me I'm concerned about
several things but particularly I'm
concerned on page
three Roman numeral 6 prohibiting any
additional commentary or other texts so
a district can't decide to include
information that would inform
citizens um possible explanations for
whatever the chart might be presenting I
don't I don't understand why we'd
prohibit that information so I believe
you're referring to lines 5 and six on
page three the correct thank you and
thank you for the question the reason
that text is there is simply that the
information is meant to be presented
with no judgment for or against it's not
meant to endorse or not endorse the
school's policies or spending it is
simply to convey the spending in terms
of where the money is going it's not
meant to impose judgment and the school
district frankly shouldn't be including
commentary and on posting a a simple
chart followup yes RIP followup thank
you could you please expand on your last
statement that the school district
shouldn't be
making comment well if they want to
address those comments or if they want
to um explain the chart in Greater
detail there's nothing stopping them
from doing so at a Schoolboard meeting
or hearing this is the report as
published um and post it it's simply a
chart representative
Tanner thank you thank you for taking my
question yes ma'am and I I asked this
every time I see this as the uh
finishing Salvo on one of these bills it
uh line on page three line 16 through
through
19 um could you point out what part of
this bill might be um held in valid or
unconstitutional such invalidity or not
other
Provisions it's difficult for me to
predict necessarily which part of it
might in the future be somehow not
upheld um there is for
example um the Civil remedy section
which is just above it lines 9 through
14 basically saying that any taxpayer in
that school district agreed by violation
District May petition Superior Court so
if in the future Superior Court ever
were to say that
um the attorney's fees can't be
awarded for example then the rest of the
bill would still stand the rest of it
would
still be
law just
followup um I'd also like to know um on
page one um from line one to line 28 um
what the documentation where where you
found the documentation for all that
information
please believe this information came
from a study performed by the Jah Bart
Center let see here I've got a copy of
the
document Ed choice.org by Economist Ben
Scali director of the uh the center
so any further
questions thank you very much yes ma'am
thank you
I would like to call on um Dr Jerry
FW thank you madam chair members of the
committee Jerry FW associate executive
director of new hamper School
administrators Association I'm here this
morning to uh voice opposition to this
particular piece of legislation first
and
foremost teacher and administrative
salaries are a matter of local
decision-making and local
control and whatever the statistics may
say those salaries have been determined
at the local level with elected
officials and taxpayer uh approval and
so um we'd like to make that that point
uh to start with but would you
believe that the original bill the
original Bill 219 as presented from the
committee was came out inexpedient to
legislate by 4 to zero vote and then on
the floor of the other chamber um a
floor amendment was introduced that
changed the complexion of the um
original 219 bill without public hearing
or without any input which is
unfortunate because we may have been
able to advise um part of this process
uh had we had that opportunity so I'm
going take that opportunity today uh to
offer some suggestions
perhaps would you believe that posting
requirements already exist for school
district budgets and the detail that
local taxpayers can access and that
information is required to be in
newspapers and notice of hearings um are
already accessible to taxpayers who are
interested in pursuing and getting that
information and at district meetings
that information is typically handed out
and discussed in depth would you
believe that the average cost per pupil
for over 10 years is already accessible
data on the New Hampshire education
department website would you also
believe that the average teacher
salaries for 10 years is already
accessible to the public on the New
Hampshire education department website
in addition would you believe that the
average minimum teacher salaries for
over 10 years is accessible to the
public on new Hampshire education
department website in addition would you
believe that the salaries for
superintendant assistant superintendents
business officials principles and
assistant principles are also accessible
to every taxpayer on the New Hampshire
education department website it's a
click and perhaps um well in addition to
that would you believe that the 10-year
based adequacy amount per student is
also included on the New Hampshire
Department of Education website as are
the ad adequacy Grant payments made to
each district for 10 years accessible
from the same report in the same manner
on a on the website if
um any of you are interested at a break
I could show you how to access that it's
simple it's simple and you have all of
the information for all of the districts
all the superintendent salaries all the
assistant superintendent salaries all
the business official salaries you have
all this
information this
prescriptive legislation which would
require line graphs biog graphs and
other types of setups are just one more
administrative burden on local school
districts to produce an additional
duplicative piece of information that
taxpayers can already
access and so if I sound frustrated for
our members am because the the
information is
available this adds one more piece one
more duplication of effort and then
there are members in this body and the
other body that will that will criticize
the administrative bloat and costs of
having to administer school districts
because we have to produce additional
information that already is in
existence civil remedies would you
believe civil remedies would be
necessary if this piece of burdensome
and duplicative legislation that's
costly to local taxpayers were passed
civil remedies I might suggest that
through the pbass system the input-based
accountability system that I believe
this uh there's a work session with this
committee this
afternoon the remedy for for including
this report uh could be part of the
pbass system there needs to be no civil
remedy and and it's accountability for
district if the interest is making sure
a district has the information available
then that could be part of the the pbass
system just like policies just like fire
safety inspections just like health
safety inspections and uh is there is
this uh information available and I
might suggest through an amendment that
if indeed the uh the interest is
taxpayer transparency and ease of
accessing this information that perhaps
the legislation could amended to
say that each School
District might be required on their web
home website to have a link to the
Department of Education reports that's
simple you have a link to the Department
of Education reports on the website so
that anyone who wants to access this
information can develop all the charts
all the Biograph all the line graphs all
the information that they want to
develop that the obligation of the local
school district would be to post have a
link on the website saves local taxpayer
money it's efficient provides the
transparency that sponsors are looking
for and it's very informative to be
honest those reports are very
informative this legislation isn't
necessary and it should be determined
itl or amended to include uh different
pieces that I alluded to and we would be
happy to work with um any language
regarding the Amendments that we um
would
propose and with that I'll conclude and
be happy to answer any questions thank
you very much are there any questions
representative
Belcher thank you madam chair and thank
you for being here this morning I wanted
to look at the opening part of your
argument which could potentially be
compelling which is the idea that um
this is a local control issue but I want
to I want to look at that just a little
bit because despite that we have
generally local control for school
districts in New Hampshire it's not
totally locally funded we have a
substantial amount of funding coming at
the state level and we're actually
facing a
pending a Supreme Court decision based
on a a decision that was rendered ear
last year that could
substantially increase the amount of
money state taxpayers are being forced
to allocate that would be then
distributed to the local level so given
the fact that yes we do have local
control but but we also have substantial
state level funding can you speak a
little bit as to why the the state level
funding issue does not override and and
suggest that people at the general state
level should have an idea of how the
money is being spent that they're
allocating thank you for the question
representative beler um I would submit
that that level of state level funding
is also part of what this legislation
could include I think it would be
important for the taxpayers to see what
the base amount is that that has been
paid per student over 10 years to their
local District so that they can
determine what the state contribution to
children's education has been what has
been had to be raised at the local level
I think that's a great point in addition
the adequacy of uh grants that are made
to the districts uh should also be
included as part of that so that once
again people can see the cost of
Education cost per pupil of their
students in their District as it relates
to the relative state contribution and
so I think that is an important piece
thank
you representative Woodcock thank you um
good morning good morning thank you for
taking my question i' like to follow up
on uh the gentleman it's my last
question uh he he indicated that there
is a significant amount of uh State
funding uh that comes at a local level
and as you had said would be uh could be
shown as as the uh equal on that on that
website would it be fair would be a fair
uh statement to say that the state
support of public education is almost
minuscule as compared to local property
taxpayers support thank you for the
question representative Woodcock um I
believe that would be fair to say thank
you any further
questions representative Tanner thank
you thank you for ask um answering my
question I want to go back to um page
two uh the cost per pupil and um one of
the the a says the total expenditure
associated with the daily operation of
schools divided by the ADM in attendance
and I just um wanted to know if you
think that's a fair assessment of what
it costs per pupil or whether there are
certain things in the operational budget
of a school that um really skews
the cost per pupil thank you for the
question
representative if I may interrupt excuse
me um I'm sorry represent over here we
couldn't hear what line we're talking
about if that's possible I'm on page two
um at the top of the page the cost per
pupil okay thank you sorry to interrupt
mam chair thank
you thank you for the question
representative Tanner
um all expenditures should be included
in the cost for people whether it's
transportation
whether it's uh administrative costs it
should all factor into the cost of
Education um for kids I think that's the
interest of the public follow so if you
if you take all the costs like the
special ed cost the transportation cost
which in some schools like karge was
tremendous um and you add that in it
really doesn't does it does it really
give a cost per pupil uh in other words
we're talking about how the the attend
the attendance the population of schools
is going
down um but we also know that for
example some of the students that need
more services is actually going up in
most of the school districts so how does
how does this cost per pupil really
reflect that thank you for that question
and and uh for bringing up that point
that cost for pupil
um needs of students have increased
needs of Staff have increased uh since
um the pandemic and
so we continually hear enrollments have
declined enrollments have declined um
true
statement what seems to be lost in those
statements are the individual needs that
have grown individual student needs that
have grown um and again I'm going to
repeat the invitation that I made
earlier if you haven't had the
opportunity to spend some time in your
local schools uh spend more than an hour
spend a week and see what those folks
are dealing with and you'll see um the
need for the expenses that are incurred
um I don't know how better to say
it representative
Damon thank you thank you for taking my
question I actually have two unrelated
questions so the first one following up
on representative Tanner's inquiry about
the cost per people at the top of page
two could you speak
to
um the B and C Alternatives
there how would a district make a
reasonable and good faith estimate or
how would doe do that that uh would you
agree that doesn't sound objective I
would agree that good faith is in beauty
is in the eyes of the beholder um you
have information and and as a school
leadership team or District leadership
team we can say we've made a good Fe
good faith effort but um what what does
that
mean we can outline the pieces that have
that have contributed to our effort but
we can't explain a
narrative because you can only do line
graphs P line graphs and um our
charts representative Heath thank you
madam chair um thank you for taking my
question one question I have about this
Reporting
System
the District of origin is responsible
for the specialed needs of those
children attending Charter Schools
that's a cost that's a direct taxpayer
cost how would this be cited in this
report thank you for the question
question representative Heath I would
respectfully suggest that would be a
question that the sponsors would need to
answer because I'm not certain um how
how you would distinguish um what
special education services you're
providing for the local public charter
schools
from from the regular neighborhood
school thank you I I have a question
about that
um Public Charter School students are
they counted as average daily membership
and attendance or average daily
membership in
Residence and this line four on page two
specifically says average daily
membership and attendance yeah I'm I
apologize representative I would have to
consult with somebody in a higher pay
grade than I to come up with the answer
to that question but it's a good one
thank you any further
questions representative Miler Madam
chair could I encourage the members of
the committee to pull the microphone
close because of the noise over here
it's hard to hear so if we can get close
that would be good thank
you representative
Damon how's
this okay um so thank you for taking my
question if you could speak to
the I'm going to call it narrative on
page
one
um I have some concerns about the
accuracy of the data that's presented
there as a foundation for the bill um
for instance perhaps you have some
awareness I'm looking at lines 11
to13 which states that over two decades
cost per pupil has increased by 77%
adjusted for inflation while teacher
salaries have increased by only
1% I wondering if you have any
information on
that thank you for the question I did
not back check that um so I I would be
comfortable commenting on it uh I would
suggest that maybe more research could
be done with that I could say in a level
of with a level of confidence that the
adequacy cost per P per pupil uh over
that same 10-year period
um didn't increase by a whole lot
either any further
questions thank you very much Dr Fu
thank you
and with that we call on Shannon
McGinley
welcome oh can you turn your mic on
please thank you chairman and members of
the education committee I appreciate
your time this morning thank you for
mentioning about talking louder because
it is really hard to hear my name is
Shannon McGinley I'm the executive
director of Cornerstone action here in
New Hampshire and I come before you
today to ask for your support of
sb29 I'm going to jump to address some
of the comments and questions that have
been made here today uh this bill adds
no great burden or inconvenience to
school districts RSA
991a colon 2 Roman numeral 2 already
requires that notice of meetings be
physically posted in at least one place
and RSA 991
1A colon 7 already provides injunctive
relief if that notice is not posted
nothing about this procedure is
fundamentally
new our team has tested this process and
are able to create mockups for school
districts manually using info available
on the New Hampshire doe website in
about 10 or 20 minutes by copying and
pasting numbers into Excel any
suggestion that this will take up time
and resources is simply false the
reality is is it will save Resources by
notifying the voters of
waste it was mentioned earlier about um
the cost of the administration being
settled by the local school district but
much of that expense is also covered at
the state level so it is relevant for us
to engage in this
conversation it was also said that the
information that is provided on these
chart charts is
redundant no it is not the school
district presents does not present clear
line graphs like this this information
that is provided on the charts indicates
Trends over the course of time which the
information on the State website does
not this the the bill is written to
prevent the information from being
presented in a way that obscures the
reality of where the money is going why
would we not want to make it easier for
the voters to be able to see this
information and the
Trends if the only problem with this
bill is that the information is
redundant and that districts will have
to spend 20 extra minutes making and
printing the graph why did the teachers
unions and other lobbyists so work so
hard against this bill in the Senate
because they know that this information
is new to the people it is clear to the
people and to the
voters so I would suggest that it is not
any greater effort to be able to provide
this information in a way that is not in
the same way presented on the State
website I'm happy to take any questions
thank you any
questions thank you very much thank you
and with that we conclude the hearing on
Senate Bill 219 and our next bill is
hearing is not scheduled until 10:15 so
we have a 15-minute
break
e
e e
welcome to everybody in the audience to
education uh today we have at this time
we have a a bill in front of us SB
379 379 is an act relative to emergency
action plans for sports related injuries
and I'd like to recognize Senator
Apprentice Prime sponsor of the
bill welcome it's good seeing you again
this
morning thank you chair lad it's good to
see you again and other members of your
committee are this morning we're just
trading floors for a little while here
so um good good morning members of um
House Education chair lad I appre
appreciate the opportunity to pre
introduce Senate Bill 379 today for the
record my name is supren s state senator
from District 5 covering a large I'm
from the up part of the Upper Valley
part of suvin County and then one uh
little great community in marac which is
New London um and it's an honor to serve
so today I'm here again to introduce 379
this bill establishes a requirement for
the placement and maintenance of our
automatic external defibrillators and
requires individuals trained in CPR to
supervise School sponsored events so the
school sponsored sports sporting events
by way of background I'm a paramedic and
actually my entrance into medicine
outside of the hospital where I spent my
career was actually in high school um I
had this interest I wasn't sure exactly
what I wanted to do and so I started
working as a student athletic trainer uh
got basic first aid responding to
emergencies on the field um and that was
I mean that was in what 198 you know
1979 1980 showing my age now things have
really um matured and progressed since
then and what we are able to do outside
the hospital and do as a team and as a
community so I have witnessed with that
experience as well as my experience as a
paramedic and as as developing and
operating trauma systems of care
including trauma trauma resuscitations
I've witnessed the value of the training
firsthand when managing these situations
that require a resuscitation of a
cardiac arrest someone whose heart has
stopped beating and they are not
breathing each member of the responding
team needs to know their role knows what
the life-saving objectives that need to
be achieved and work in a coordinated
effort proven to be lifes saving and a
example that we can put right on the
table and uh you know I'm a late in life
football fan and a late in life coffee
drinker but I was watching the game on
January was January 2 of a Monday Night
Football when Demar Hamlin suffered his
cardiac arrest and I have this kind of
place in my kitchen I call it the perch
where I watch from the breakfast bar my
husband's in front of the TV and I
remember the way he went down and I said
that's not you know like he's
unconscious okay he was unconscious his
heart stopped beating he was not
breathing and we've heard the story
since then but what this proved to us is
that that whole medical team everybody
knew what they needed to do when this
type of situation happened it's the
worst situation it is unexpected but
when it does happen if everybody lines
up and knows what they need to do we can
actually save lives and there's a just a
perfect example of how this happened and
this athlete is not only back on the
field but he's talking about how these
coordinated efforts make a difference
now I know I have folks here from the
Heart Association today that will shed
more light on cardiac arrest and cardiac
arrest resuscitation uh but just a few
other things before um I wrap and take
questions is that um you may recall that
in 2021 Senator G Canon um put to he he
passed legislation and I was actually a
new Senator and worked with him that put
Lo he put local boards or school
districts and their boards or the
governing body of each of each body of
each public and nonpublic school that
includes grades 4 through 12 that they
have an emergency action plan so they
have a plan I was also back in my days
when I was the chief of Emergency
Medical Services we had an initiative
here and I sat on the AED commission
which was established by the legislature
and has now since sunsetted to make sure
to find ways to fund we had a large gift
to get this started but but on top of
that to fund putting automatic external
defibrillators I clearly have not had
enough coffee I was with my daughter at
the Boston Marathon yesterday so it was
a little bit of a long day very proud
she ran that 26 miles um to put an AED
in every school okay and we were able to
accomplish that and actually even though
this isn't a school setting there's an
AED on every floor and I believe that
you representative leakas were
responsible for getting that done we
have them in the state house um and we
have them you know almost everywhere
It's Not Unusual to see them in an
airport but the reason is because we
know that time matters okay so I've had
this experience of working to get these
into the schools we have a plan but
taking this just one step further is
that when you have a plan you actually
have to drill that plan so we know at
schools that there are fire drills so
that folks the children and the staff
and the teachers know how to respond we
also know unfortunately we have active
shooter drills so again people know how
to respond in my business as a paramedic
and working in trauma resuscitation we
would practice our responses so that we
could say you know take we would save
time execute identify where we needed if
we needed any changes or updates
additional training and then move
forward so if this ever happened which
we don't want it to happen we were ready
to go so the aeds are there we have the
staff and as I understand that there's
some athletic trainers that are here
with us but they are coaching staff
there's somebody within the coaching
staff and the athletic training staff
that already are required to have CPR so
we have folks that are CPR trained and
we have a plan and we have the AED so
now let's put all of these things
together make sure everybody knows what
to do so I appreciate the opportunity to
introduce 379 I'm hoping that we can
bring this um I can gain your support
and we can get this out of committee
with an a to pass certainly I'm open to
any questions you might have thank you
chair lad and members of um House
Education thank you very much Senator
Apprentice uh are you willing to take
questions absolutely represent
leus can you ex oh first thank you for
taking my question and thank you for
putting this in and I absolutely
love not locked in a whatever within one
you know it's awesome I just have a
question about H which is require that
an individual trained in CPR supervise
organized School sponsored sports
activities and I'm wondering if you can
tell me what you mean by that supervise
the activities so thank you U
representative leas for the question and
that's come up before and that might be
an area that uh we need to Tinker with
because the I the the process is that
there needs to be or the thinking is
that there needs to be somebody who is
CPR trained who is at a school sponsored
sporting event that can be part of not
only conducting the training but you
know responsible for at least initiating
the resuscitation efforts until the
medical folks get there but there seems
to be this question that's come up
before about what exactly are these
events and what should this look like
okay so I don't think it fully answers
your question but it is on my mind thank
you you're welcome further questions
from the committee represent Miler thank
you Mr chair thank you for being here
could you tell us how much does one of
these units cost thank you
representative Miler for your question
so you can a an AED can run anywhere
from $1,000 to
$1,500 up to $ 3500 00 they are very
public friendly in fact I don't know if
the state does this anymore but for a
number of years the department of safety
working with purchase and um plants
purchase and property had they would go
out every year and they would bid for um
the defibrillator contract and then
publicize this so that entities could
come in like school systems and get a
defibrillator automatic exteral
defibrillator that was safe ready to go
at the at a at a reasonable price thank
you further questions representative
penell thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question I just want to um
this came up in the last hearing I just
want to make a quick reminder that it's
hard to hear over the noise it was
easier when I was chering U anyway my
question is how do you envision this
looking on a at a school where multiple
practices are occurring because I'm sure
these emergency events occur during
practice as well as during a game
thank you representative P
Pon real Pell P I know you schooled me
last week and see we're already not
there um great question I'm going to ask
that the athletic trainers help to
answer that question because you're you
know a smaller school might have you
know one practice taking place but there
are larger schools that will have
multiple um and so it's my I don't it's
my intention and understanding that
there is a plan to manage that entire
field but I think that they can speak
best from the firsthand experience so if
you can hold that that would be great
further questions represented Tanner
thank you and thank you for bringing
this forward I think it's really a an
important um Bill we at school districts
we have been doing emergency planning a
lot of emergency planning for evacuation
fire drills and that sort of thing and
and to a certain extent I think that
that um sports injuries have been um
really uh addressed a lot by uh
certifying coaches and and certainly an
athletic trainer that over oversees the
extracurricular or
co-curricular um sporting program um but
I think as uh representative petrell has
said that you know there are a lot of
sporting events that go on at a at a
school and other events like theater and
and you know where you get the outside
public and sometimes we've had I know
when I was teaching we had um couple
cardiac arrests that that uh came from
people coming into the building as well
as people in the building as well as
staff or students so you know it's it's
pretty um pretty comprehensive so I
think that um the plan should include
the AED you know throughout the whole
building not just the this the sports
aspect um I I noticed that you had the
the
main the main purpose of this or the
main direction of this was to the to the
local school board but I would say that
the school nurse and the athletic
director are probably the two key people
and um maybe the local school board
would would have them you know as as the
people that they direct to set up this
program but certainly they're the most
qualified within the in the school
district to do that and I'd almost say
that um I would like to see that pointed
out as far as the local school board
with the direction of the school nursing
staff and the school nurse staff and the
athletic director um so that it's it's
uh you know comprehensive okay okay you
and I don't know if that's a question or
not but
that thank you yeah are you are you
finished Senator all all's just G may I
just quickly respond back briefly thank
you so much representative L um
representative Tanner one of the things
that this so I think your points about
um you know School nurses and athletic
directors how that go Works down and
coordinates at their level many times
the School nurses are there just
respectfully it's a big job during the
day where the athletic uh staff is there
more so after hours and on weekends and
that can be different given the district
but something you point out it's
addressed in this bill but I think it's
important to note um that the AED can't
be locked up in one particular place um
and because these have become so
incredibly affordable we're finding
multiple aeds at school so the athletic
staff may have one that just goes with
them but it's very U during my tenure in
doing this type of work I tried to
respect the um the you know the I call
it like the brick and mor of the
building but really encourage that folks
don't lock up like life-saving equipment
in places where people can't get to it
when they need it so I thank you for
raising that point represent Damon you
had your hand up and then represent
Terry thank you Mr chair my question
follows thank you for taking my question
Senator follows what you were just
saying which the bill language says if
the school has aeds can you inform us
about how common is it to all have aeds
and if not would you entertain an
amendment requiring schools to have them
so thank you representative Damon so
there is an AED so we don't require
schools to have aeds but what we did is
set up a commission um it was in
2002 um and I was working back as the
chief of Emergency Medical Services
during that time this Commission was set
up to take a large gift given to the
state as well as look for other funding
to put aeds in schools so that everybody
had access to one because you know at
that time even though it was still there
were these very affordable units it's
was a reach for some of the smaller
districts so uh we worked to get an AED
in every school stepping short of
mandating that now the a every AED
including in a school has to be
registered with 911 and that's the best
place to locate the list of automatic
external defibrillators and there's
somebody that actually works at the New
Hampshire fire academy who supports the
school systems in this so it's I'm
comfortable in saying that they exist in
every school I just can't tell you
exactly where they're located 911 could
uh but the purpose I think it's
important to get out of the the building
and make sure it's on the field and
available thank you represent Terry so
do I understand uh just a follow and
then my own question if I might so do I
understand your response to
representative Damon's question that
aeds are not required by state law but
that it is your view that most school
districts have aeds as a matter of good
policy shall we say that is my
understanding okay so thank you my um I
appreciate the illustration that you
gave with respect to the football league
and um sure that um we're all aware that
the a sports professional sports
organization such as the NFL would have
such a policy in place I would expect
the same for the other professional
sports uh leagues and uh to the the NCAA
as well so um my question to you is with
what you're proposing in this uh in this
legislation would would this make uh New
Hampshire a a leader or or a follower
shall we say in terms of of uh enacting
these kinds of requirements and I'm all
in favor of uh being a leader when uh
something good is about to happen but
I'm just wondering uh have you been in
conversation or done any research with
respect to how these kinds of concerns
are being addressed in um in other
states in the country thank you for the
question representative Terry um yes and
in fact we would become the leader um
and you'll I believe we'll hear from the
Corey Stringer Institute that is you
know the lead you know a leading um
organization in our country around
Sports safety and with all of the
different pieces now together having
aeds C you know CPR training and action
plan and requiring the drilling of that
plan puts us in puts us out as the
leader in this country thank you you're
welcome thank you represent
belshire thank you Mr chair and thank
you for being here this morning um first
off I'm I'm hugely supportive of the
concept of of getting aeds out
especially linking in the sports teams
especially given the the apparent
increase in cardiac conditions we've
seen in young athletes in recent years
so my question though is a little bit of
language might it seems to me might be
cleaned up a little bit so I wanted to
ask you about what methodology you would
you envision when it comes to um the
three minute within the three minute
rule of being available what what kind
of methodology do you think should be
employed to establish whether that can
be on site is it is it uh should they
physically going through a test where
they're walking from one location to
another with a stopwatch or or what what
do you envision there thank you
representative beler so we use the three
minute Mark as you know start like where
the clock starts on our ability to save
lives number one so thank you for
bringing that up um in cardiac breast
situations number two is by taking
making sure that the
naed is available in the athletic
setting first of all in the schools but
in the athletic setting and having it
close by will start to start to again
methodology drive that window down and
lastly if everybody knows what they have
to do where it is and what they have to
do it will also from a methodology
perspective start to keep that as close
as we can to three minutes does that
answer your question if I may that
that's all good information but I I was
thinking more nuts and bolts is how do
we establish if it's actually capable of
getting there in 3 minutes so if it's if
it's somewhere in a building in a room
and the school is going to say well that
we can get that there within three
minutes how should they test that should
they actually get the stopwatch out and
watch walk it over thank you uh
represent beler great question again
making sure first of all that it's not
in a room and bringing it to where it
needs to be is going to be is going to
be the first point but they can they can
test any way they want including using a
stopwatch I mean it is if I may just
give illustrate ever so quickly that you
know in doing so um trauma
resuscitations so that's been the work
that I do is you know managing systems
of trauma care and when we would
actually drill in either the simulation
lab or actually in the emergency
department and we would time our
responses from when the ambulance hit
the door to getting them in the bed to
when the tests were ordered to make sure
that the standards that were put forward
that we were able to meet those so that
is an example of how it's done because
that's you know that's been well that's
been the standard in that setting so
it's bringing that to this setting in
the athletic and on the athletic FS so I
think between both of those questions
hopefully are answers I got you where
you need to be but I I appreciate your
question welcome Senator Apprentice um
we we can't hear on this side when
you're not speaking into the mic so I am
so sorry so just we were talking about
different ways to actually
test but it was difficult so sorry
because of the we got I know across the
street sorry represent
Woodcock good morning Senator thank you
for for being here um I appreciate the
bill others if I could follow up on what
representative Tanner highlighted um I
say that because having been a college
athletic director for a while um I
understand the issues
uh and also being high school principal
that what happen to school and most the
ones I've seen at last summer at the JB
football scrimmage uh it was the
grandfather went down yeah when I saw at
the high school was the grandfather or
grandmother in the watching this the
performance in the auditorium so I'm
wondering if this and I I support
athletic part I'm with you I'm just
wondering if we shouldn't have it at all
events instead of say just all sports
activities all School sponsor events
because I'm guessing that the of those
injur that that would require an AED are
not necessarily athletes at the junior
high and high school level there may be
an occasional hot issue but um these are
probably The Spectators and parents and
grandparents that are there still in the
building or teacher the staff
considering how they aging and some
places um so may maybe that's that's a
thought and the second one is that if
that was so you what you're thinking of
that that was sort of that addressment
the line H and the the other one was um
I'm concerned if I may follow up Mr
chair yes thank you um I'm concerned
about the uh in 18 sen other words the
school will regular check um it reminds
me of the regulation we have now the
principal walks around the brilliant end
of the year and checks on the HVAC
system and they just check it off until
you know we still have air coming in um
so I'm wondering if there if there
shouldn't I don't know who that is who
what that means who in the school or
agency I'm not sure anyone in our school
uh would be able to do anything with the
manufacturers the train is absolutely
they know what they're doing the top
notch I mean in a regular school setting
um if that's an annual piece I don't
know how we Define that do you have any
thoughts on that just trying to make it
better I'm not trying to kill no no so
um thank you representative Woodcock and
uh one of the most important things that
we actually can do besides putting the
system in place tying all of these uh
pieces together is making sure that when
the equipment is needed it's ready to go
um and just like at the beginning of
like every ambulance shift you would
make sure that you know everything was
working and if it wasn't then you made
sure that it was so that you could
appropriately respond I mean we so we
could drill down and you know require
that the school is part of their action
plan I and I might need to go back and
look at the plan um has a specific
design so if we want to put that
language in there that it just becomes I
am I I've never been a school teacher
God God bless um and but I have been a
student an athletic trainer shouldn't we
uh make sure like give them the uh the
guard rails to get this done without
telling them exactly when they can you
do it but put somebody in charge and
what the basic requirements are one of
the things I found with the schools is
that they all share this information
like some schools have an actual
checklist and they you know there's
things that they go in terms of checking
lock you know certain doors that need to
be locked um alarm systems are in place
and oh stop at the AED and make sure the
pads have not expired that the machine
is accessible that the batteries are in
date and are ready to go and they have
like a checklist that they go through
and then that checklist could be saved
and kept in a in a nurse's office or in
a athletic trainer's office wherever the
AED ends up being I don't know if that
helps get there but I think we could I'm
keeping a list of the things that we
could maybe be more directive on um and
I'm happy to work with the member of
this committee and getting that done
thank you so much for your comments
you're welcome thank you Senator penis I
have a couple questions for you here uh
in previous testimony did you was there
anything given to this bill from
nhiaa New Hampshire inter Scholastic
Athletic Association did they testify be
for or against really testing my memory
back to early January I can pull the he
oh you know what wait a minute I have
the hearing report so I don't remember
them being here being there but that
doesn't mean let's see Cory Stringer
Institute athletic trainer kobby Sawyer
College
uh government relations for the Heart
Association so I'm not they did not
testify um okay although they may have
signed in I just don't have a list of
the individuals okay so I have some
followup questions then um I'm looking
at if the school has a
aeds um so that just wipes out those
that don't and that's that's a concern
to me I think this is an important issue
where there should be aeds beable period
um and I noticed not that on item number
three on line 24 the AED should be on
site I would say it shall be on site and
the reasoning behind that is you're very
familiar with the town that I'm
from and been there and probably got a
lot of training there the community
Athletic Field is not part of the high
school and so it's a separate facility
you're never going to get up that school
within three minutes um so that's one
issue should it be
on site where and the other issue I have
you the third question would be why is
this to be initiated in September 1 2024
after the athletic season starts August
1 and that's when it's the hottest out
there that's when it's likely to have
some issues going on um so that's that's
a consideration we may want to and I
realize this is
a kind of a you might say unfunded
mandate if you require it but from what
I gather from your initial conversation
at $1,000 to $1,500 per
AED uh maybe at Max of
$3,500 I I think that it might be
Pennywise pound foolish you know not go
that direction of requiring them so if
you could ask the other questions I
appreciate it
so would your question so I think we've
got the Scholastic Association who got
to find get their position on this and
they may be here to testified today I
haven't looked at the sheet I wouldn't I
wouldn't know or it would be hard for me
to understand why they wouldn't be
supportive of this where many of the
sports medicine School sports medicine
organizations are but In fairness I will
check on that second is should versus
shall so uh representative lad I think
they should be they sh I think there
should be a shall but I'm also sensitive
to saying you shall have an AED you
shall put it here we know that this
works it is being um
it's like being cautious around the
Mandate issue but at the same time these
have become much more affordable and
they are in New Hampshire schools so we
could put sh versus should um that um
that is you know I think that's up for
discussion U and then the startup time
on this I was just trying to build
you're right the the season where
student athletes in particular are
getting ready for football field hockey
soccer whatever it is they're doing in
the hottest time of year it would make
the most sense to have this in place uh
but I was trying to be respective of a
ramp up period depending on the side of
the sides of the school district to get
the message out to coordinate the plan
and get this going so I think there's um
I'd love to hear I would like to hear
from the athletic trainers on what they
think this might look like and I hope
that helps okay thank you further
question representative Tanner thank you
I just Paul I just want to uh go back to
the three minute um rule uh I think
that's going to be difficult
particularly you know we we had multiple
fields in multiple places um offsite
onsite all over the place um and I think
the the key is at least from my training
was that CPR be started as soon as
possible as soon as it's recognized
there's no pulse no no breathing and um
you know we've had situations where we
had CPR going for you know 3 minutes and
then an AED show up or even longer than
that and an AED show up and still be
effective so um you know I and schools
can afford one but you know they in a
big school like Manchester or even even
curar where you've got you know seven
schools feeding into that seven or eight
schools feeding into that you've got a
lot of activities going on do and so I
think I think that three minute might be
uh something that we want to be as a s
suggestion rather than you know a hard
fast Rule and and really stress that I
would stress that all staff all
teachers all coaches all theater people
anybody that deals with the public
through the public school system be
trained in CPR in first aid um just
basic
so that's my two
cents thank you representative Tanner
much appreciate it represent
Hall thank you thank you and thank you
for taking my question so as a
supervisor and coach of many clubs and
teams I had to do the training every two
years but I have to say I thank God
nobody ever had a heart attack on my
watch because in those trainings you're
learning about you know EP pens and
broken arms and CPR and that's one piece
of it I I wouldn't want to be that
person that had to do it so I guess I'm
asking about lines 29 and 30 is there
more than that CP that American Red
Cross certificate you would get after
this training like I would feel much
more comfortable with a the trainer
being on site than me being on site you
wouldn't want to have a heart attack on
my watch um so I'm just curious on not
29 and 30 is it that two every twoyear
card and that's the person is that what
would qualify me to be this person y
okay representative PA yes and I'll
don't underestimate what you could do
with your training in an emergency I in
all of my years doing U this work I've
just been so proud of the members of the
public who step up uh you know they took
that CPR class and they learned how to
use deed and it just K you know they and
they're you know so glad that they took
the time to do that because they were
equipped so don't underestimate what you
exactly could do when there was an
emergency okay well that's good because
they took the class probably 15 times
every 30 years 15 times I took that
let's get a new one for
you thank you okay thank you very much
we have five more cards all right and I
think I'm going to have to go to the
three minute rule on that as well but
are there any more questions of Senator
yes represent
beler thank you Mr shair thank you we we
kind of between us came up with a
thought that might possibly need to be
addressed I I would suggest in the bill
and I want to see if you would be
supportive of um so with an AED being
available one thought might be to okay
well we're going to take the ad that
exists and bring it out to the location
on site to be at the athletic field but
I would be of the opinion that you
should never remove in AED from an
advertised location as long as that
building is occupied by anyone because
they would expect it to be there so this
may require the purchasing of
substantial numbers of new aeds so what
what what would you suggest as far as
the the money piece on this and whether
do you think that's feasible um to put
on local schools or does there need to
be some sort of
some sort of modification here to
actually draw something from the uh the
education trust fund or or or what for
this so thank you for your question
representative belter I'm going to make
sure to speak into the microphone for
everybody so I'll
so the the number one point here in this
legislation is it shouldn't be locked up
in respectfully the school nurse's
office and we used to see that it could
be this could be the opportunity for
schools to reevaluate cuz I agree with
you like if it's an advertis that
there's an AED going to be there and
there's a crisis and you go look for the
AED because somebody in the who is
watching the you know is at the school
play or in another event has a cardiac
arrest it's out on the athletic field so
there may be U I'd like to think about
how to address that in this language
where there's strategic location I don't
think this requires additional purchases
and I'm going to speak to that in a
second but just thinking about
strategically where it's located and
making sure it's not um locked anywhere
and that if it is moved that everybody
knows where it's gone but let me say
this about the the financial side of
this is I don't it's been my experience
since we've started working in this area
that charitable organizations Kanas
clubs rotary clubs U the one in one
Community I worked with the GU the
gardening club raised the money and
bought the bought an AED to put it in a
specific location so I think that we can
address strategically located making
sure where the that everybody knows
where this is so they can get it when
they need it without actually adding you
know a fiscal note to this and helping
the locals get it
done represent Terry thank you so as we
continue to talk about this and envision
different scenarios under which the aeds
may be
needed I'm thinking to my own personal
experience when um I was on my high
school baseball member of my high school
baseball team back in the last century
unfortunately the last century uh I'm so
old but uh we were it the field would
not have been uh within 3 minutes of the
school building which would therefore
require that an an AED would have been
on site at that particular location for
the game same thing with my college
where my college baseball team the home
field was actually 50 15 minutes away in
the city park and not on campus so there
would need to be an
AED uh that's on site for that
particular event and you need somebody
who was uh somebody or somebody's who
were trained uh to do that and this kind
of feeds off of Representative bel's
concern so it would seemed to me that
each school then would have to assess
how many aeds would be needed the
maximum number that would be needed and
the maximum number of persons that would
needed to be trained but practically
speaking we're we're probably looking at
maybe two or three on average and not
just one does that make sense have I got
this the the the field is located 5
minutes away or 10 minutes away or 15
minutes away where the school is the
home team and therefore is required to
have the AED on site so now we don't
have an AED for another team that may be
playing on campus and it's a volleyball
game and then we have the concern about
the one being you in the school so there
would be a need for multiple aeds and
multiple persons who would be trained to
know how to use them so correct correct
okay so thank you represent I don't see
this as an impediment I'm just trying to
drill down on here is anybody who would
think that maybe you'd only need one per
school is not being realistic you you're
going to you're going to have schools
where you're going to require multiple
aeds and persons who are trained which
is fine yeah thank you very thank you
for the question and I look forward um
although I have to get back to S
education and I really like to stay
because I'm passionate about this I
think that between the Heart Association
and the athletic trainers we can get a
better feeling for or understanding of
how the logistics are currently working
and where we may have to build in some
guard rails to this to give flexibility
to the to the schools and the school
systems while still achieving the goal
of working to reduce the time to get 911
called CPR started an AED in place and
everyone know what to do thank you thank
you very much and thank you very much
Senator Apprentice I'm going to be
respectful of your time as well so have
fun at Senate Ed thank you very much um
representative lad is that strawberry
milk pardon me is is that strawberry
milk it it was but it's water oh I was
just appre appr bring me back to my
school days okay you know recycling
right to the desk centuries ago thank
you very much everyone you're more than
welcome no it's not hatchin milk all
right uh so I'd like to uh we're going
to impose a three minute rule that means
you have three minutes to present and
then you have questions following that
so the first card up is Emily
Knight good morning everyone thank you
so much for hearing my voice here today
my name is Emily Knight I am a resident
of straford New Hampshire I am a nurse
of 30 years in wles hospital I run the
American Heart Association training
center there I am on the board of
directors for American Heart Association
I sit on the state committee for sudden
Youth and infant death I um go to DC to
talk about these issues as well and I'm
extremely passionate about saving
children's lives I also have two
children of my own that were student
athletes that went to cobon high school
here in the state and I just want to
speak very quickly about the importance
of aeds I'm hearing you all um talking
about the importance of CPR which is the
first step of saving lives however as we
are learning at my state committee um
the incidence of congenital anomalies
that are causing sudden cardiac death in
children is on the rise it's not going
to be at some point just the
grandparents having cardiac arrests in
these sports stadiums it's going to be
the students having cardiac arrests
because of these congenital anomalies
that they have um and the only way to
save them is not CPR we need
defibrillation we need aeds we need
these kids to get energy and that is how
we save them and we save them into
beautiful souls like Piper or other
children that I have seen in the
community in my hospital and across the
state at our Community um that it really
really does make a
difference um I want to tell you that I
understand I hear you talking about the
financial piece of this and I agree uh
that we have many many ways to raise
money for this important equipment um
and I definitely support this bill and
I'm open to any questions you might have
thank you very much other quit represent
Myer thank you Mr jar thank you for
being here uh you indicate that the
issue the incident rate of heart issues
and young people is on the increase uh
what's the what's the reason for that so
we don't know exactly but I will tell
you this when I started on the sudden
youth death committee about 7 years ago
we could test for 45 of what we felt was
150 congenital anomalies that cause
sudden cardiac death in infants and
children we can now test for about 95
but we believe there to be over 450 in 7
years we've seen that much of an
increase in the genetics that are
changing in humans that will cause these
sudden cardiac deaths thank you further
questions from the
committee thank you very
much uh Molly McDon uh
McDougall welcome Molly
thank you my name is Molly McDougall I
am currently the certified athletic
trainer at kirar Regional High School um
and I just wanted to share my support
for this bill in August of 2021 in the
first no disregard not me yet operator
air go ahead um in August of 2021 in the
first 20 minutes of a field hockey
practice during preseason we had an
athlete collapse she was not breathing
she had no pulse and she had obviously
suffered a sudden cardiac emergency
thankfully our coaches knew how to enact
our emergency action plan while one
coach started CPR another called 911 and
the last one called me which was the
most critical point because I came with
the
AED within 45 seconds of the a athlete
collapsing the AED was placed and myself
and the coaches were able to revive the
athlete between the AED and the
sufficient the efficient CPR between
myself and our Coach Piper here was able
to be revived on the field and is able
to be with here with us today Piper
needed two rounds of CPR and constant
monitoring from the AED to stabilize her
this process took no more than 4 minutes
but was enough to save her life karge is
approximately 12 minutes from New London
Hospital which is a small facility um on
the day of Piper's accident we waited 17
minutes for an ambulance to
arrive so I firmly believe that due to
our up-to-date emergency action plans
the and the components of s SP 379 that
we already have in place uh that we
would not have had the same outcome for
Piper our success and Piper's life all
hinged on a written document the access
to an AED and individuals that knew how
to do CPR uh my coaches and I were able
to save a life that day with nothing
more than that knowledge and we were
able to get someone's child home to them
that day so I am in full support of this
bill and think we should all think
carefully about it thank you very much
other questions yes represent
pel thank you I was told to hold this
question for you so it's about a large
camp we have a large campus where
multiple athletes are practicing we do
have a our athletic trainer does have a
gator that he drives around however we
also have the um track team that
practices at a different
location um with the so I guess I have
two what would you do about the cross
country team that's not necessarily on
campus and the students are athletes are
spread out
running you might not the coach might
not even be able to get to the athlete
who's down in 3 minutes
of course um it's a very tricky
situation because if you're like our
school they run in the woods sometimes
too so part of that is making sure that
everybody knows what the plan is um so
our coaches run with a phone on them so
that they can call 911 but also say that
they can call me and meeting in the
middle can get that AED to someone
quicker um so that is a big part of it
as well I know we all assume that it's
going to be someone coming from the
situation to the AED and then coming
back in that 3-minute window um but a
lot of the times like in Piper situation
it was me coming to them and that's why
we got the AED so quickly so knowing
where that team is going and knowing how
to get to them as quickly as possible
it's part of the reason that I run our
cross country trail every year to make
sure I know where we are and the best
way to get to them um but having both
stationary and mobile aeds is really the
the key component there thank you
further question representative
Woodcock good morning thank you so much
for being here um to follow up on your
your K size experiment experience uh in
when the um typical trainer in the
typical high school uh today are
students uh screened at all for the
congenital anomalies or bringing
information like that that uh Miss night
was talking about or is it just is just
uh the typical athletic physical of old
days more often than not it is the
typical physical that we get however
there are some schools in the state that
do host these screenings um and they are
you know based school by school you can
have someone come in and and do these
screenings which could also be a part of
keeping our athletes safer absolutely
thank you thank you so much further
questions representative
Tanner hi thanks so much for being here
and thank you for what you do um do you
have any idea how many approximately how
many schools in New Hampshire actually
have an athletic trainer like your
Serge I don't know the exact number off
the top of my head we do have a running
list of secondary school which is how we
all keep in touch with each other um I'd
say it's pretty split down the middle
with what schools do and don't have them
at this
point further questions thank you very
much thank you like to invite Piper
Moran we've heard your name spoken to
already today welcome Piper thank you so
my name is Piper Moran I want to thank
all of you for hearing me today and I
just wanted to reiterate the importance
of having an AED on our school and the
athletic trainer um I guess I'm just
kind of living proof of the example of
why we need it um if we didn't have an
amazing action plan or athletic director
like or athletic trainer like Molly um I
probably wouldn't be here today so it is
very important to just keep that in mind
about why we need the AED and everything
so yeah thank you Piper yeah are there
questions
thank you very much we're just very
happy that you're still here with
us uh Rebecca
Sterns uh is that
yeah good morning good
morning I'm Becca Sterns I'm an athletic
trainer and I'm also the CEO of the
Corey Stringer Institute we were founded
in
2010 in honor of Cory Stringer who was a
Minnesota Vikings who passed away from
an exertional heat stroke
we were founded with the mission to
provide research advocacy uh
consultation and to prevent uh sudden
death in the athlete war fighter and
laborer and sudden Cardiac Arrest as
you've already heard today accounts for
uh the greatest number of athlete deaths
for any condition so uh on average it
accounts for 60% of all the deaths we
see every year in athletes which results
in about one athlete collapsing every 3
days from a sudden cardia
arrest and so the fact is that time is
of the essence with sudden Cardiac
Arrest that's why it is so deadly and
why it is the number one cause of death
in athletes so for every minute that
passes without the application of an AED
that chance of survival goes down by 10%
so by the time you hit five minutes the
chance of survival is a flip of a coin
okay so so that is why we're talking
today about the location of these aeds
this bill just to answer a few of the
questions that have already come come up
doesn't necessarily require aeds though
I would love to see that but it does
require strategic placement and
maintenance of those
aeds and to put it in perspective as
well the cost of an AED is about the
cost of two football
helmets
so what I want to also impress upon
everyone today is that we know that the
survival rates can be as high as
89% when you have these items in place
when you have an AED within 1 3 minutes
and when you have somebody trained to
apply that AED these are the two
critical components that this bill
provides New Hampshire has are already
implemented many programs that have also
enhanced steps critical to address
sudden cardiac arrest so it does include
that distribution of the aeds in the
early 2000s which I think was around 450
aeds it also provides negotiated uh ACC
or access to lowcost aeds through the
state negotiated plan that you've heard
of today as well as well as a
coordination between the 911 calls that
come in and the location of those
registered aeds to ensure that the
closest AED is accessed when that
life-saving call comes
in so in general an AED is a basic
health and safety protection that I
believe all student athletes deserve
access to it's similar for other health
and safety uh equipment for other safety
Provisions that we have schools do have
to fund various aspects of sports
programs it includes equipment
maintenance of the fields Transportation
coaching so the cost of an AED the cost
of having someone trained to use that
AED is really dwarfed in comparison to
the entire Athletics
budget the passage of the predecessor to
this bill in 2001 or sorry
2021 uh put New Hampshire among the top
five states to prioritize High School
sport athlete health and safety
the passage of this bill would continue
to propel that trajectory forward and
established New Hampshire as a model for
many other states to
follow so thank you for your time today
and I'm happy to answer any questions
thank you very much yes representative
Woodcock good morning good morning
thanks again for being here as
representative tnah say the 8's job is
of just telling represent people under
under
under underpaid
overworked um have seen repres Woodcock
we can't hear what you're saying can you
move your mic closer please good morning
okay that helps anyhow so my my going
back to your comment on if I'm want sure
I heard this correctly one athletic one
athlete uh collapsing every three
days currently is this a nationwide or
Statewide that's a Nationwide Nationwide
okay that's a little better um uh follow
up please thank you
um couple other things are are the
trainer not trainers are the coaches in
New Hampshire at the secondary level um
required to have uh AED training I
believe the head coaches are not all
coaches are required though okay so if
that coach is out that day it leaves the
team vulnerable and just one last
question if I may uh typically do the
high schools in the secondary level that
have aeds uh at the by with the trainer
they typically travel on GES with them
as well besides one to school yeah great
question so um there are portable and
they're also stationary ads so in terms
of the pl placements in uh strategic
locations um we do encourage and it is
really typical to have a portable AED so
that AED could realistically cover
multiple sites if they're close to each
other right so you don't have to have an
AED specifically for every single field
of course larger programs are going to
need more but uh the smaller programs
could probably have one or two that
would be able to cover the fields
because that one could be mobile and it
could be on the active site thank you so
much M are there further yes
representative Damon thank you Mr chair
thank you for being here um I recall
being trained on how to use an
AED when they were first being placed in
in community places and it was in the
office building that I worked in I'm
wondering for if you would share for
folks who didn't ever do a training and
are not MediCal providers and just have
no experience with
this what that training is like and and
what the uh time frame for it is thank
you yeah great question too um there's
been so many advances recently with the
training that's available you can take a
CPR AED training online the nfhs
actually has that course online and
offers it um for High School uh programs
for this very reason so the options are
are Bountiful I would say and so I think
you can take a course that might be in
the realm of 15 to 20 minutes it can be
as reasonable as $10 I think there's
even some programs that you could find
it free um and uh I think one of the
greatest advantages um because we're not
expecting everyone to be a medical
provider the purpose of this is to allow
someone to recognize when something is
terribly wrong and know the first steps
so that further care can be
summoned great answer thank you thank
you further questions from the committee
not see thank you very much thank you
uh I'd like to invite Nancy
vaugh good morning chairman lad
honorable members of the committee um
for the record I am Nancy Bond
government relations director for the
American Heart Association um and I uh I
worked closely with SRA prenis to uh to
craft this piece of legislation this
year um I am uh I'm humbled by the
expertise of the people who have come um
before you today other than myself on
this issue um and I would would say
definitely to um to let us know if you
have any questions Beyond today um I'm
sure they'd be happy to answer um answer
your questions I do have written
testimony so I will try my best not to
read through this but I'm trying to find
um some of the questions that were asked
but again we are obviously in support of
this policy um what you have heard um
today is there you know in this
situation of is currently available for
aeds um we do feel that there is um you
know a a good amount of coverage of aeds
in schools in New Hampshire I would be
very happy to work with any of you next
year on putting through a bill to seek
funding for schools for this issue um
whether it's cost of CPR training for
all teachers whether it is cost of aeds
um that um schools might need to add to
um because next year is a budget year um
but would ask that we not pass on what
is a good policy um for this year for
the ideal pal policy at this point so I
urge you um to pass this bill um I
also um I think really what this bill
accomplishes um is uh for those that
currently have aeds the training is
already required of um of these teams
for the Emergency action plans um but it
is really you know having these steps
that not all schools may have in place
in their emergency action plan for
cardiac arrest um to make sure that they
do have these in place if you have an
AED according to current state law um
you really need to follow the
maintenance on this there needs to be a
person and expected user that is trained
um on the AED so that would be the point
person for making sure that these aeds
are maintained and that the batteries
are working and all of that um it's not
really left to the school board or the
school principal to do that unless the
school principal is also the uh the
person for for School athletics um and
uh I would also say that um because
these emergency action plans need to be
coordinated with your local EMS the
local fire rescue are great resources to
schools to all of us actually um and
they usually are very open to coming to
locations and offering trainings but
also that schools should rely on their
Fire EMS rescue um to talk about
placement and how many aeds that that
school might need um for that's not
something that this group is is alone in
in planning um planning out how many
that they need and um you know we we
would be um one of the the um early
states to pass this legislation um this
year and it really is about these these
steps being in place the rehearsing of
the plan this is how we know whether we
can get that AED within 3 minutes to the
side of the person or the the rehearsals
that the teams would be doing um leading
up it really should be something that
they do throughout the school year but
at least once a year to be able to do
that so um in in um uh in respect for
time and your time I am going to turn in
my written testimony and I'm happy to
follow up with any of you beyond today
but if you have any questions for me
today obviously I'll try to answer them
thank you very much are there any
questions today represent
luno thank you very much so um so um
Nancy you rais a really good point about
next year but given the incidences um
and things I'm not sure why we wouldn't
consider um uh consider a state
appropriation on that this year through
through the um the you know the the
finance um committee and and we we've
heard testimony right that that an AED
is about
$1,500 they are but I understand through
the state um uh Department of Safety
Bureau of EMS that these are actually
available at more like under a
I've heard about 800 so then so then
these numbers would be a conservative um
$1,500 time five aeds at each School
times 300 schools across the state we're
talking a little over $2 million okay
yep why wouldn't we put that in this
bill I I think as as a direct State
appropriation yes I think if if there
was the the funding to do that I would
feel you know I would definitely support
it no matter what um because I do think
think the sooner we can get this done
the better I just wouldn't like to see
this this Bill end up um you know dying
in early death because there's a fiscal
note that that couldn't be be covered
this year the these steps that don't
require costs are really important for
for them to have in their plans this
this year so so so just for just for
background followup yeah um there's uh
there's over $200 million in Surplus in
the education trust fund okay and and
the um the legislature passed bills last
week to use 100 million of that for
Equitable grants this seems like a very
good use would you agree that this seems
like a very good use I think this is an
excellent use of funds um whether we
have them or don't have them this is an
excellent use of funds this is the lives
of children so yes I agree with you
thank you very much are there any other
questions from the committee yes
representative Belcher thank you Mr
chair and thank you for being here and I
I just want to ask you uh if you would
support a little bit of a a a different
idea but I think it meets the the the
needs of what we're looking at here
because I honestly I don't think there's
any way to do this without more EDS ads
being involved um if we were to uh draw
from the uh the available funds we have
to instead of Furnishing these directly
to each individual school if we were to
do it let's say by District um in a way
that accounts for the different student
populations by District so that they can
sh be shared between schools because if
you provide it to a school it it may you
know four days out of the week just be
locked you know in an office somewhere
but in the district level it seems to me
that we might be able to get this done
for well under a million dollars do you
think that would be something that might
be again I I would definitely support
that that um that idea y thank you
definitely further question repres
Woodcock good morning thank you for
being here miss f u I'm trying to think
about from the civilian walking by the
ad as we have here uh if I recall and
it's not accurate I'm sure at one point
it was the ads that that I had seen were
pretty much self toage as you needed
them yes um are they still is that mode
so people understand what we're talking
about we're not talking about a you know
highly just thank you yeah no thank you
for that question aeds are incredibly
easy to use they basically you hit the
on button and the AED will tell you the
rest it will tell you um you know to
apply the pads to the individual's chest
it will then do an assessment of that
patient is a shock advised and then it
will tell you a shock is is advised and
basically you know take your hands off
the patient and the device will do the
the the shock you will not be able to
shock a person who doesn't need to have
that that shock um and the important
part of calling 911 is there is a person
who will be on the other end of the
phone telling you everything that you
need to know as well because sometimes
things go out of our heads when the
emergency happens you know the more we
practice the better we get at it but yes
very easy to use f question yeah thank
thank you for that and I just wanted to
dispells people hear that a and they're
like oh my goodness how can we do that
yeah thank you so much appreciate it oh
thank you are there further
questions thank you very much for coming
today uh one last card here um Mary
anner from the New Hampshire athletic
trainers
Association good morning good morning my
name is marir I am the President of the
New Hampshire athletic trainers
Association thank you for allowing me
some time this morning I do have written
testimony but I will submit that for you
um and I just wanted to address some of
the questions that have come up that
have not yet been answered by my
colleagues or um to embellish on them a
little bit further uh so great question
about um does the AED tell us what to do
a and AED stands for automated um so
there are certainly defibrillators in
hospital settings that do not prompt you
what to do but the ones that are out in
the community um certainly do and walk
you through those steps as well as the
dispatcher um in contacting with
911 um our folks at uh the Cory Stringer
Institute with Becca um the data tells
us that in the state of New Hampshire
approximately 60% of schools have access
to an athletic trainer um so it's the um
it's the athletic IC training
association standpoint number one of
course we're in favor of this bill um
but furthermore we want to think about
um Equity across the state in getting
support to students at schools that do
not have access to specially trained
individuals uh like myself and my
colleagues so um it's just important to
realize that when we talk about our
examples with how the athletic training
staff is going to get an AED to folks
there is a number of schools inside our
state that the AED is not going to be
coming from the athletic training staff
and we're going to lean on other
stakeholders in those schools in order
to get this work done um so again that
speaks to the multi-practice question um
that was that was asked before what do
we do when there's multiple things going
on what do we do when there is not an
athletic trainer that speaks to the
importance of having those emergency
action plans be very very comprehensive
in their list of stakeholders part of
the very first thing we have to do is
identify who exactly who is present at
these um at these events you know
whether it's extra or co-curricular um
is clear on exactly what their job is
right down to who opens the gates to be
able to get the ambulance onto a planing
surface so there's a number of people
who are involved um who would be
identified and then of course um as
we'll see in uh in that line 14 on part
two they have to be rehearsed and the
rehearsal is really what I I many of our
colleagues will tell you is the most
important part the plan just can't exist
and be Lo locked away in a drawer we
have to know what it is and we have to
be able to do it um so spontaneous
drilling is um is encouraged when we're
learning about emergency action plans um
and follow up on the maintenance
question where it said you know
maintenance would be required and we we
were questioning who exactly is
responsible for that maintenance um the
language here allows for the entity that
needs to come up with that plan to have
some autonomy in choosing who that
person is based on their available
resources um those of us who have
experience inside educational um
facilities realized that most of us wear
multiple hats um and we're pulled in
many many different directions so it
absolutely will depend on the
organization what those resources may or
may not look like so I I appreciate that
the language allows the school to have
or or the organization to have the
autonomy to make that choice um and
lastly there was a question about um the
nhi aa's um involvement so on the last
iteration of this um we did work sorry
go ahead thank you collaboratively with
the nhiaa they are aware that we're here
today as well as well as the New
Hampshire Ada um and last time the nhiaa
was neutral on The Stance but they do um
they do encourage this type of work um
they do require that their coaches are
first aid CPR and AED trained so any um
any school that participates in the NHA
is under that framework of expectation
but again it's important to note that we
have many um educational facilities and
organizations that fall outside the
jurisdiction of the nhiaa so work like
this also supports that schools in in
those situations have access to the
education and the resource and also
their those requirements for training
thank you for your time thank you very
much other questions yes representative
Damon thank you Mr chair thank you for
being here and informing us um I think
your statement was 60% of schools have
athletic trainers and if I have that
number correct is that a New Hampshire
statistic and is it what grade level
schools um I believe that the um the
atlas survey does include some of the um
Middle School aged so it probably starts
around seventh grade I could be is that
correct six okay yeah 7 through 12 um
and that is 60% is our own state number
yes thank you you're welcome further
questions from the committee not see
thank you very much thank you so that I
don't have any more pink cards so that
closes this hearing for
379 we'll take uh five minutes and start
the next one up for those that need to
take a
break
e
e e
Now with uh Senate Bill 442
and this is a bill relative to student
eligibility for Education Freedom
accounts and the scholarship
organization cost of administrating the
program extending phase out grants for
Education Freedom accounts and revising
the definition of average daily
membership and attendance in average
daily membership and residence
representative or Senator Lang I'm back
you read that title all over again it
sounded really good no uh so I'm Senator
Tim Lang I serve Senate District 2 which
is the Lakes Region on the west side of
the lake uh CER Bradley covers the east
side of the lake and Center Gray the
south side of the lake anyway um so
going talk about our favorite topic uh
efas um this bill does four basic things
um the first thing it does is raises
eligibility from 350% to 400% of pover
federal poverty level just to give you
an idea what that means and I'm sure
you've all seen the uh the numbers but
currently um for a family of two uh 350%
of federal poverty level is
71,543 1800 to put that in
perspective median incomes in the state
of New Hampshire and this is by age
population which is important because
we're talking about families and you
know probably under 25 we're not talking
about a whole lot of families but over
25 uh we are so the median 2024 income
for under 25 is
58,221
856 from 45 to 64 it's 11
14,313 and for 65 and all their median
income is
$59,950 so again to give you a
perspective um thinking about uh
families uh two family households or two
kids and and two parents as a
four-person household again the meeting
incomes 101 um the um this bill would
raise the EFA eligibility level to
124 uh 800 so again we're aiming for
that middle uh element uh 50% of the uh
population median income um and making
them available I could you know that's
working poor if you're a family of four
making a uh
103,2 180 124,000 you have two kids
that's a tight budget um having raised
four kids myself so the first thing this
bill does is raise it to 400% the second
thing this bill does is change the
scholarship organizations um
administrative costs dropping it from
10% to
8% the next thing this does is is to
deal with the phase out grants as many
of you know in the first year of a phase
out School gets a certain amount of
money then next year when a student
leaves for and participates in the EA
program that public school still gets
money um it gets 50% of of it and then
the second year gets 25% even though the
student doesn't go to that school any
longer um this extends those phase out
grants from ending in 2026 out to
2029 the next thing this bill does is
create a reporting requirement on
Department of Education to um report out
uh to the uh uh executive Governor's
Council uh and Council as well as a
legislative oversight committee how much
money is being spent in the phase out
Grant so how many public how much money
are public schools getting for students
that no longer exist because they've
left the public school and and joined
the EFA program
um sorry I apologize the next thing we
we do in this bill is just expanding uh
again four public schools that we know
that while efas are are very successful
there are some topics that are hard to
teach in an EFA program
uh I'm going to use high school physics
as an example um so if you have a
physics program what this would allow is
an EFA student to attend to public
school and and give credit to that
public school for 15% of a full-time
student um in additional Revenue to that
school to be able to support those
programs that allow EFA students to come
in and it extends it as in a previous
Bill uh all the way down to seventh
grade through 12th grade um that's the
Fast and the uh Furious of it I'm happy
to take questions thank you very much
Senator are there questions from the
committee not seeing any thank you very
much represent Woodcock thank
you sen Lang welcome um I'm looking at
the uh physical
note and it doesn't say what the cost
would be raising it to
400% it doesn't say
anything can you give us an idea what
that might be
uh so again my understanding and and
back of the envelope conversation so to
speak is it would increase the cost of
bfas by uh the current budget amount by
about 25% and that may Mr go ahead and
that would be what uh I'm doing again
I'm hoping you know hold me hard to this
number if the current cost is I would
say by $10 million roughly how much
about $10 million
roughly
oh again that's just trying to do math
in my head really fast when you're
asking me the questions so I could be
off okay um just yeah thank you
uh is that is this budget in the budget
for this year well again because this
bill wouldn't take effect till next year
be next year's budget so it has to
budget and remember the you know as as
the chairman of ways and means and the
Senate I pay attention to revenues and
what's going on remember the education
trust fund will have an estimate at the
end of this year uh $212 million
Surplus and that's still funding all of
the current education funding costs that
we have relative to EFA so uh even
though we've increased the cost of that
has gone up we're still ending with a
surplus in the in the education chest
fund and if I the last question thank
you Mr chairman um I I bring this up
because of the Surplus in the education
trust fund and the need as you're
indicating to moving this to 400% I'm
I'm I'm wondering why particularly on
Ways and Means and you're happen to be
here the questions are terrific um why
the meals Bill died in the table uh and
was not funded for student meals when
they're looking at 200 or 300% for kids
who need as this is that came to your
committee uh thank you for your question
I'm not sure that bill came to my
committee that would have probably went
to I don't recall oh it did actually but
not as ways and means I'm like that
wasn't in my ways of means that was my
education committee side right education
committee again um if you remember we
had a commission that studied that and
recommended future legislation that bill
that was brought forward wasn't
inconsistent with the recommendations of
that
committee thank you representative Heath
thank you Mr chair I have a a question
uh thank you Mr representative
representative L
um we've had efas in in place for a
while as we have probably over 10,000
children being
homeschooled and um I'm a long-term
educator and over the years I've seen
many unfortunate things come across the
the roles
um can you explain to me how in fact you
can assure the safety of all the
children participating in an EFA that
you know that they're in a safe and
healthy environment and indeed they're
getting the kind of objective education
that that we would like our public
taxpayer money being spent on so thank
you for your question so again I think
first off if you look at the court right
the court the court presumption in the
state of New Hampshire is that every
parent's a fit parent so as legislators
we should take that same um as a
legislative body at branch of government
we should take that same position that
the presumption is that every parent is
a fit parent it's up to the state to
prove otherwise um so I would argue that
I every parent is a fit parent just just
as the court says every on a Case by
case Cas students do have under in home
school as well as uh public private
school there are some standards they
have to meet it's not just a free-for
all there are assessments that have to
be met or um and I apologize I don't
remember off the top of what it's called
but there's a where an educator will go
in and look at a portfolio of a child
and certify that the child's meet and
need the educational requirements are
remind you that New Hampshire has a
compulsory education requirement right
we require every student has to go to
school right so the question you're
asking is do I think that that only
means public school and that when we
talk about the word cherished in our
Constitution that we talk about only
cherishing for public school purposes or
do we just cherish the child in general
and all children in the state of New
Hampshire regardless of their family's
income and for me I I I cherish all
children so I think the state because it
set the obligation to have a mandatory
compulsory education should cherish all
students in all forms of Education that
works for that child because that's
what's in the best interest of that
child further questions from the
committee representative
beler thank you Mr chair and thank you
Senator L for being here um to follow up
just a little bit on the last question
when it comes to uh oversight of
homeschooling communities and whatnot of
course we have to look to our ultimate
law which is the constitution in New
Hampshire and I'm trying to remember the
exact phrasing but would you suggest
that the constitution of the State of
New Hampshire says that we the
government must maintain a constant
oversight of the people or does it
suggest that the people should actually
have a constant oversight of the
government I'm sorry I don't quite
understand your question I the general
the general principle is that people
oversight government not government
oversight people thank you repr Miler
thank you Mr chair and thank you Lang
for being here I'm sure you're
aware that in the last three years of
this
program that the EFA program has been
$28 million over budget are you aware of
that I'm aware that's been a very
successful program we had more children
apply than we thought were going to
apply but you're aware that it is over
budget each of those years thank you the
next question I have is are you aware
that the uh Commissioner of Education is
not allowing the LBA to do a full audit
of how this money is being expended
through the uh agent that is monitoring
this program are you aware of that thank
you big question so I serve on that
committee the the that that hearing was
held in front of and the audit the audit
committee I was present in the room when
the commissioner spoke and I was pres in
the room when the LBA spoke and I was
presid in the room when the AG
spoke what the commissioner said was he
will fulfill the law 1135 that was done
he will provide the information within
his control that he's he's authorized to
release also within the contract law of
the State of New Hampshire um that he's
authorized to release the Attorney
General backed him up on there are
certain data that by contract law we we
can't do however what I will tell you in
the latest update is Mike kanaine and
the lb's office and the commission of
Education have come to an agreement and
that audit will be done and the audit
will be completed so again the
Commissioners always said that based on
law both both the stat law and the
contract law he will do the audit he
will provide all the information he's
allowed to by law and by contract law
that was clear in the public hearing it
was just misrepresented everywhere else
there are some things he does not have
the authority to release and we can't
force him to release that data so again
I will say that the commissioner said
clearly the law that the information he
has that's within his control he will
release the information that's
contractually he's allowed to release he
will release and that audit is going
forward and there should be a letter
coming from the LBA and the exe and the
commissioner stating that
clearly representative uh yes
representative uh cascaden thank you Mr
chair uh thank you for being here
Senator Lang um you talk about on line
19 of page one talks about reporting
requirements and I guess my question is
we are all very um interested in making
sure all our kids make good Pro progress
why wouldn't you have a bullet there to
report out academic achievement if these
students are receiving public
monies so thank you big question again
this was relative to phase out the
extension of the phase out grants we
felt if we were extending the phas out
grants that the Department of Education
should let us know how much money is
being spent on that topic on on the
phase out grants so this was to create a
clear reporting process because in fact
we're changing that law um and that as
we extend out the phase out grants that
will give give Public Schools money for
kids that are no longer in their
District um that have moved on will
continue to give them money we want to
know how much money that was that looked
like follow up follow up um so that
wasn't my question my question is why
would you not want to make academic
achievement public in a reporting for
students who access these funds so thank
you for that again it wasn't a focus of
the Bill thank you further questions yes
representative pno thank you Mr chair
and thank you for my question Senator
Lang
um it's come to my attention that there
are several families who are waiting for
the um income cap on efas to be
increased so that they can participate
are you aware of any families that are
waiting for this to occur considering
literally I just left a couple minutes
ago the 500% Bill downstairs and the
testimony that was going on with that
yes I've heard from families that uh are
are in waiting list to be able to get to
schools that meet their child's needs
and because and they're waiting for the
uh income verification to move up again
these are working families there were
some good examples down there about a
dental hygienist and a janitor who might
be married and how much money they make
and whether they're eligible to be able
to provide an education that fits their
child other than a public school uh
model and um and again the testimony was
that this bill even the 400% I think
would have done it but the 500% would
definitely do it um move those families
that I consider you know you know the
old oldfashioned middle class we used to
talk about the Working Families that
probably still are maybe not quite
paycheck to paycheck but pretty darn
close to paycheck to paycheck type of it
would give them that flexibility to be
able to go and and one thing I'd remind
everybody is that again when we give
assistance to these families and we take
away that cost to the family that just
increases again if they're living
paycheck to paycheck it gives them
better food security better better
housing security because there's more
money freed up for them to be able to
provide food for their children and
housing for their children they may have
sacrificed um in order to get their
child into an an education service that
works for them and the parents have
sacrifice just just eases that burden in
that sacrifice just a little bit again
increasing the ability for them to put
food on their table for their
children
yes thank you so your your examples are
families who are already making
sacrifices by working two jobs to put
food on their tables for their children
absolutely representa Tanner thank you
thank you for taking mine does this
still
remain uh that they only have to make
that qualification of income level when
they initially apply and if their fiscal
or their income changes over the period
of time that that the child can take the
parents can take the voucher for the
child um which goes up I believe until
they're
21 um it doesn't ever recheck that so
they may start out at at the the 400%
level but if their income increases it
doesn't above that it doesn't make any
difference they continue on the voucher
program thank you
yes further represent
Damon thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question excuse me so at the
beginning of your introduction I believe
your statement was we know efas are very
successful I would like you to please
tell us um what your definition of
successful in this context is and how
we're measuring that sure thank you for
the question so again I think the
original statement of um the fact that
families are are recognizing the need
for this program right they they see the
need for this program and it's helping
it's helping them again if you've had
and I'm sure this committee has had EFA
testimony and had child after child come
up and talk about how successful their
um actual implementation of efas have
been for them how they how they've done
and what they've done we just had it
again we just had a 500 Bill downstairs
and we had several children come in and
speak about how it made a difference to
them moving from a public school to a to
a a a a different school that worked for
them that was unique that fit their
unique model um and their unique needs
and so I'd argue that a I'm sure you've
heard that testimony so that's
successful to me when a kid walks in and
says I like school um that is hugely
different than a kid who walks to a
public school and says I wish I could
leave here um and and that testimony so
um again I'd argue that successful to me
is the fact that we're having students
engaged in um in this program parents
are engaging in this program and that
makes it successful and then again we
have an oversight committee that's
that's working and I met yesterday as a
matter of fact again the Ed the
education Freedom account oversight
committee met yesterday um we do have
standards in place for these schools
again that they have to take they either
have to have a portfolio reviewed by a
certified teacher um uh and I there's
three mechanisms I can't remember I'm
sure the chairman could site them off
the top of his head but I don't remember
them off the top of my head um that
review student portfolios at the end of
the year to show that the students
making progress are
successful yeah the three are you have a
portfolio review by a certified teacher
or or a teacher that's working with kids
the other one is you have the Statewide
assessment and the other one is a norm
referenced assessment which is a
nationally Norm referenced assessment
those are the three so those those those
are metrics underneath that which a
student is measured uh outside of the
public school system uh reps and
Woodcock thank you uh s Lang just more
on the EFA and not on the food question
if I may uh you you U answered
representative Damon here that your
determination of success was that the
students were engaged and the parents
were engaged so that was
successful um is accurate assessment to
say that around 80% of the of the
families that are participating
initially in the efas were already
attending other private
schools so I I don't know the exact
numbers I won't say a percentage because
I don't I haven't reviewed it recently
to see what this year's numbers were I
remember last year's numbers but not
this year's um I I'll remind you again
right these are all families and again
last year was 300% of poverty this year
is at 350% of poverty next year if this
bill passes be 400% but we're talking
about families at 300% of poverty level
right so again any money we give them to
help them with their educational need
even if they are sacrificing now only
goes to make that child's home life
better just follow up Mr chairman yes
follow please so the question C Lang was
even using last year's numbers the
things we heard from the doe we're still
looking last year at 350 at 80% of those
youngsters enrolled I'm not suggesting
they aren't happy uh in their parochial
schools but these aren't students who
came from public schools because they
were dissatisfied I'm not kind of homes
school students that are whole different
pieces you're talking about so it's not
like the when you're using the
measurement that the only criteria is
students engaged and successful parents
engaged successful but they were already
engaged they were already going
somewhere else Cana public school so so
again I'm just going to say that you're
right that they were that that a portion
of the students current in the current
EFA program were going but again last
year's numbers would have been years
before numbers based some 300% of
poverty not 350 so remember reporting
requirements so it's up 300% of poverty
again um and I don't have the number for
go ahead 300% poverty but again I'd I'd
argue and say that those parents were
sacrifices and they were doing it
because in the best interest of their
child and we made those sacrifices a
little bit softer by allowing them to be
able to participate again making the
likelihood that they were able to put
food on their table that much easier
which I think is something we should you
know help with we did try to put food in
the table and that wasn't successful
downstairs is that a followup
question is that a follow-up question no
just a statement thank you thank you uh
representative Pam thank you and thank
you for taking my question again this is
in regards to the phase out grants have
we seen and and the need to extend them
have we seen any school districts that
have had such significant numbers of
students fleeing for to utilize the
education Freedom accounts that it's
significantly affecting their funding we
have not um but um again as some of you
know I was the author of the education
funding formula this year and we were
looking at at student reductions and
looking forward next 10 years we're
anticipating 1% per year going forward
um just a normal um decrements of of
Education of Public School attendance um
never mind that this additional uh where
where things might move so again we want
to be respectful of the fact that you
can't turn on a dime uh public education
government doesn't work that way and so
we're giving a little bit of breathing
room to allow these public schools to be
able to adapt their um spending to match
to match their actual enrollment but
we're not trying to make them turn on a
dime yes representative B Bon
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question I have a question
about actually the funding mechanism
that you're talking about um and when
you talk about the 0.15 per people uh so
if somebody takes an EFA Grant which on
the average is uh
$5,200 right now I think um if I I'm
trying to figure out the is that what
the um the adma amount would be so at
0.15 of 5 $200 is
$780 uh per course um and does that
money is that come is that additional
money that the Department of Education
is going to pay or does that come out of
the awarded uh EFA So currently that
would be additional money the Department
of Education would have to pay um it
would it would again be attached to um
their annual ad Rick knows this number I
I'm drawn off the blank but the ADM or
adma the um or admr I don't remember
which it is but um it allows that at the
end of the school year um for the
because we all know that everything's
reported off one year one budget cycle
off one one year off um the reported
number of full-time students or eligible
students would be incremented by by 15%
of the student for an EFA student that
attended a public school so they would
get an increased share of uh education
funding and that would be based on um
again all of the metrics okay repr
um so just to confirm that's additional
money so the EFA would remain that
amount what is there any um cap on how
many classes uh one of these students
could
take I get where you going with this I
don't know the answer to your question
thank you I don't I think in order the
qualify again I just I think I don't
know what the rules say at what point a
student becomes a full-time student and
therefore would be knowledable for an
EA just to so my where I was going and
as you probably understand is that
there's really no loss of the EA money
that would be going to the family and
yet uh the department would be providing
additional funds to the school district
per course we want correct we want to
support our Public Schools as best we
can further further
questions not see any thank you very
much Senator have a good afternoon uh
Tim Horgan and I'm going to Institute
the three minute rule from this point
forward because the prime sponsor has
presented y probably standing between
you and lunch so I'm represent Timothy
Horgan for straford County District 10
which is the town of Duram so and I'm
opposed to this bill actually there's
two sections that I like one
um section three the uh reporting uh
about the reporting oh well part about
the reporting requirements um I'm not
sure about the details but that seems
like a reasonable idea um and actually
section two I really like which is it
reduces the uh cut that the scholarship
organization which is the children's
scholarship fund of New Hampshire takes
from 10% to 8% so I definitely applaud
reducing the amount of money we're
giving giving them to administer the
program they um don't seem to be
struggling too much they were they're
their lobbyist was downstairs handing
out those orange scarves although maybe
they printed up tens of thousands of
scars and just it's a sunk cost I don't
know for sure but they were handing out
those scars they bust those uh children
ref Ling uh mentioned we're bust in from
from L from from a school in lonia which
is one of the major users of uh of of
EFA grants certainly I think it's may
even be the largest non-religious user
of EFA grants um so my main objection is
uh first of all for reducing um
increasing the uh reducing the uh income
threshold from 350 to 400% um cuz I I
and and I know any anywhere you anywhere
you set this there going to be some
families that are on the wrong side of
the uh of the threshold that's
unavoidable for any you know any
entitlement program like this but I
think uh raising it just given the many
many problems with the program um which
I think uh I think we go down the road
we're going we're going to have a fiscal
disaster you know we have this uh
program that we keep ex keep expanding
without much thought there's like a very
minimal oversight of it a lot of the
oversight is turned over to this
organization which even though it has
New Hampshire's name is in fact based in
New York City in Midtown Manhattan um
and which seems not to be hurting too
much for money um and I also
uh I think I just think that's a bad
idea it's mostly just the whole program
I think is a disaster waiting to happen
and also there are a couple things you
can but even that first section you
could use that as a vehicle for fixing
the problem that a family qualifies you
you could get a kid probably in
kindergarten qualify them and then 12
years later they're still eligible even
though in most cases the parents will be
making uh more money than they did when
when the kid was little since their
lives are evolving their careers are
expanding along as the kids go through
school and um this of course is also
that would be that would be a gerain
Amendment you could just pass it on your
own if you want to do it and also this
is a vehicle that would be appropriate
if you have if you have second thoughts
about how we treated the um hb212 the
late art Ellison's lunch bill
um that uh that's also a vehicle you
could use if you feel like going ahead
and uh and passing that because that was
certainly um I suppose at least in my
opinion that was just sort of an
embarrassing situation there that we so
I would I
would anyway I oppos to build but there
are a couple of things that are pretty
good especially um reducing the amount
of money that the CSF of of New
Hampshire gets so I guess i' be happy to
take any questions thank you very much
representative are there questions from
the
committee oh repres yes represent wock
thank you thank you uh president Hogan
you seem to be pretty well versed uh
every time you come here in uh the
background of the bill and particularly
entitlement programs do you know of any
entitlement programs that people can
qualify for one year and safe for life
oh absolutely not all of them I think
all of them you do have to qualify at
least once a year and you're required if
your income increases you're supposed to
usually supposed to report to the agency
that's administering it which is um
usually a government agency usually
thank you yeah thanks further questions
from the committee not seeing thank you
very much like to call forward Deborah f
okay good afternoon chairman like
members of the House Education committee
uh I'm Deborah house from the American
Federation of teachers New Hampshire and
I'm here on behalf of our 3700 members
across the state to uh speak in
opposition of Senate Bill
442 um we represent K through2 Educators
across the state uh as well as public
university
employees private university employ
employees and town employees we are
parents and grandparents of school
children in New Hampshire as well as
property taxpayers and we do oppose this
bill uh every Grant State student has a
constitutional right to a robust
education through a public school
district um this is not just our opinion
this is something that has come down
through court cases over the past 30
years and that is a robust education
with professional certified teachers and
special Educators small class sizes
school nurse and counselors and behavior
Specialists well stocked School library
plenty of opportunity for Hands-On
experiential learning this must be
equally robust in Berlin Franklin
Claremont as it is in Bedford Windam and
Hanover and the state has to fund this
and the reason I'm bringing this up is
because as we all know tax revenue is
limited and as the courts have found
they put a number on this the state is
short about 537 million a year in how it
funds its public education so that that
robust education is equally real for
students no matter what district they're
in so funding and any Voucher
Program gets in the way of making sure
that opportunity is just as real for
every single student no matter what
district they're end expanding voucher
programs will make it harder to fulfill
your constitutional duty to all of those
grand State students who have a right to
a robust public education so raising the
income cap from 350 to 400% as nice as
it might be as much as you might want to
do it just is not affordable just like
we can't afford so we heard last week
to free to feed kids free lunch in
school no matter how hungry they might
be we can't afford to do this um SB
442 would increase spending on
vouchers to 53.4 million a year
potentially if all the people who are
eligible under that new cap took it up
with 30 million of that being new
spending and um for students who are
already in some kind of PR private
educational setting whether that's
private school home school or some
learning pod or whatever setting they're
in at a time when State revenues are
already not coming in at projections so
they're softening and um the existing
surpluses are rapidly being spoken for
with many important priorities we can't
afford to expand this
program is it a good use of our limited
tax money that's a great question
because the record of educational
achievement is not publicly reviewable I
understand there are you know reviews
being done but we the public don't get
to see that so you can see how students
at a public school not the individual
students but can see overwhel how
they're doing with this program we don't
get to see what the success rate or
non-success rate is and in other voucher
programs when the data has been allowed
to be studied the ACH achievement has
been shown to be um academically
disastrous worse than even the um
disruptions of Hurricane Katrina or the
disruptions of Co on schools and with
that I will close here but I will email
the testimony you can read the closing
paragraph thank you very much are there
questions representative dry then
represent thank you very much thank you
for taking my question um and how can we
increase funding to vouchers if the only
voucher program was repealed decades ago
well we've had this conversation before
and you know it's still a
v represent Bel thank you Mr chair and
thank you for taking my question um you
you estimate that this bill could um
increase our spending on efas to roughly
50 some odd million yep um you've
described that as uh unaffordable we're
currently awaiting a Supreme Court
decision which may or may not uphold a
lower court decision with a fiscal
impact for taxpayers well north of a
billion dollars which is perhaps 30 40
50 times as much as this amount would
you consider that to be affordable are
you talking about the school funding
lawsuit yes which is your constitutional
obligation to All gred State
children are you saying you you
um want to
D asking you the question would you
consider that to be
affordable I I'm saying you have
constitutional obligation I expect you
to meet it thank you very much uh repres
luno thank you very much Mr chairman
good timing for this question given the
last one um you uh you refer to around
$53 million of all the students um
available you're talking about all the
students who are currently attending
private schools I'm talking all the
students who would fit the demographic
regardless of where they're attending
whether they're in public school or in
private school or in or in any sort of
private educational setting I mean I I I
just want to sort of follow on on that a
little bit so if 400% is is roughly you
know a little you know a little above a
little around right around median
household income
Statewide um I no no but yeah I I I do
not know for sure if that is an accurate
statement so I will not stipulate that
but so so so it it's it's it's a round
media household uh income state and
we've got 165,000 kids so half of them
are on one side of that number half of
them on the other side of that number so
um so if all the students in that
demographic it would be closer to like
500 or $600 million if 80,000 kids
82,000 kids uh went into the program the
53 million my understanding is these
These are kids that are that are already
attending private schools and I mean
that's where that numbered from that's
been most of the experience so far
though is that it's been but if but if
but if every school every student who
fell into that that that demographic
left their private school public their
public school and took a took an EFA
we're talking about adequacy the the
$5,200 average cost for 82,000 students
wouldn't that be about right okay yeah
true I mean that that's actually thank
you than you for um you know correcting
my unclear statement so we are not
expecting all of these students who
could
possibly take it to leave public schools
because most families want their kids in
a public school where they're with all
the children from their Community from
their neighborhood where they are uh you
with their friends from down the street
and across the town where they're having
these common experiences in community
with other students from around them um
most families want that common
experience and they trust their local
neighborhood public schools to educate
their children and they are happy to
have that so um the worst case scenario
you're right is assuming that most of
the students are already taking a u a
private educational option in that
demographic between 350 and 400 would
take up the option of getting money to
help them with that option they're
already exercising great thank you very
much yeah further questions from the
committee not seeing it thank you very
much uh next C is Brian
Hawkins thank you Mr chairman good
afternoon I'll try and I know right
before lunch so I'll try and be
cognizant of that um I and not repeat uh
what others have said for the record
Brian Hawkins representing Nea New
Hampshire today um first off I just like
to say you know we just expanded the
eligibility for this program not even
one year ago um and here we are looking
to expand again um it was already
mentioned
that there has not been an estimate for
this program that has come in under or
at budget um we're already over uh if
you include um some of the most recent
numbers we're probably at about $24.5
million dollars a year on spending um
and so uh and yesterday at the uh EFA
oversight committee the from the
children's scholarship fund they
indicated at this point in the year
there's an additional 500 applicants
coming for the
fall this is just April uh I'll just
remind the committee this is a rolling
application process and so that uh so
we're there's still room to grow there
and that is under the current uh budget
and current um
eligibility uh one other thing I just
mentioned Senator Lang mentioned I think
in his testimony that this would take
effect in the next budget um this as I
read it unless I have the wrong version
of this it says 60 days after passage um
so we will be in the current budget
until July excuse me June 30th of 20 25
um uh performance was mentioned um I
think it is premature to expand the
program before we've seen the
performance audit that was mentioned but
also uh there were several things that
um the uh education Freedom account
oversight committee mentioned for their
recommendations in their in their recent
um report that the scholarship fund
should be required to provide an endof
year report and that that commit should
Define what that is they haven't done
that yet the committee should Define who
are the program stakeholders they just
started talking about that yesterday
three identify current and future tool
metrics for student performance and
accountability including how the school
and educational setting demonstrate
accountability we haven't done that yet
number four Define successful graduation
versus program completion that has not
been done and then an annual check for
program eligibility number five and the
Senate did talk about inserting
something like that into this bill but
they uh they did not um last thing I
will
mention is there was a mention about the
portfolio the portfolio can be looked at
by a non-public school teacher as well
as certified teacher so it uh it can be
by a non-certified and that is selected
by the parent so just wanted to close
with a couple clarifying points and I
will conclude there happy to take any
questions thank you very much are there
questions uh represent
belshire thank you Mr chair and thank
you for being here and taking my
question you mentioned that we we've
recently expanded this program the CFA
program and that's absolutely correct um
but I'm I'm looking to kind of get to
the heart of the issue of expanding the
EFA program so given the fact that
courts have upheld the fact that the EFA
program is one leg or plank or whatever
you want to call it of the methods by
which New Hampshire residents can
receive a public education because it's
publicly funded what is the either legal
principle or philosophical principle for
limiting the funding of a public
education to one group of citizens but
not to another group of
citizens um so I would have to uh go
back and look at the uh Court decision
there was a recent dismissal of a court
decision that we were not a part of but
um I don't believe that it stated that
the that this
program um met the obligation for um a
an adequate education uh or or a public
education in fact I think that was part
of the reason that they Justified
dismissing the case was that this
program is an optional program it's not
the required constitutional obligation
um that we have to meet to every student
and every student can uh cannot be
discriminated by a public school like
they can an EFA
provider if I may just a real quick
follow up on that given given that
argument which I think is you know in
keeping and logically consistent would
you then argue that the EFA program
itself is actually an unconstitutional
program I well not being a judge I'm not
sure I can answer that question but I do
have a lot of concerns about this
program that I think I've mentioned
before when testifying on this bill one
uh Central
constitutional uh question is um Can a
state agency uh delegate rulemaking
authority to a private entity and and at
least uh as it appears they the state
has given the department the ability to
do that because it is the scholarship
organization which can determine what is
an educational expense and that very in
my view would fall under
uh something that should fall under the
state's purview in in deciding that
because we're spending uh public dollars
so I guess there's one example where I
would at the very least question the
constitutionality of this program um not
to mention the fact that uh president
house mentioned early we we haven't
fulfilled the Constitutional obligation
for uh a public adequate education um
yet and we're still working on that so I
think we need to address that first
first uh before we um continue to expand
this uh this program thank you very much
represent
Woodcock Mr H good afternoon good
afternoon thank you for being here uh
Senator Lang in his
presentation uh when was asked to Define
if the program
successful uh he said the students
engaged in the parents are engaged and
we know based on his numbers that 80%
minimally have know come to public
school um and I know that you have a
background in public education and and
in metrics would you seem that that' be
a reasonable measurement of success in a
public school program to say if the kids
are engaged the parents are
engaged I think that if I understand
your question correctly um we have a
broad array of ways in which we define
success in public education and
it um while I mentioned assessments it
doesn't fall only on test scores um and
I think that is the central benefit to
being able to
offer uh a free public education to all
students is that uh it can encor it can
Encompass um more uh it can Encompass
serving um that child and that family um
Beyond just um you know in a assessment
thank Youk you further questions from
the committee represent
luus I want to go back to something that
you said thank you for answering my
question if if a business isn't
budgeting correctly do you blame the
customers or the person who budgeted and
would it not make sense instead of
saying oh this was under budgeted to
instead come up with a more reasonable
budget I think the legislature should do
more due diligence when it comes to this
program I um you know one of the things
that uh I think many people in the
public have struggled with was the fact
that uh we we sent um the bill that was
heard in the Senate um this morning um
without it having gone to the house
finance committee in fact I don't think
there has been an EFA Bill since its
Inception which has gone to the house
finance committee um as a standalone
Bill uh and I think that is partly why
we're in the position that we're in is
that there hasn't been that fiscal
analysis that has been done by previous
um legislatures prior to that because
once they did delve into it uh they
found that it it you know these were uh
they were concerned about the numbers
and how it would impact uh not only
taxpayers but public schools and
students and so I think that um we need
to start sending these types of bills to
the finance committee for that kind of
analysis further questions from the
committee not seeing it thank you very
much thank you very much have a good
lunch thank you Brian uh Mary
wkey thank you for hanging in there
thank you for hanging in there now I
know I better really talk fast because
lunch is waiting um I'm Mary Wilkey from
conquer and um I'm against the expansion
of the eligib eligibility requirements
in this bill um I've talked about
similar bills here so I won't repeat
what I've said in the past but um one
point I did make in the past is that um
it would be prudent to wait at least
until the legislatively mandated audit
takes place before expanding the program
because uh let's make sure that there
aren't what if they come up with some
problems or some risks that haven't been
addressed we should address those before
sending even more millions of dollars uh
to the voucher program um I still
believe that and I believe it even more
so having uh watched the testimony that
was given at the legislative at that
joint committee where the
um the the LBA was concerned about not
being able to get the data they needed
to do the audit that you all as
legislators required and I'm not privy
to whatever negotiations have gone on
since then that Senator langry referred
to so maybe they've agreed to a full and
complete audit I would applaud that I
don't know why it would have to get to
negotiate to do that um but you could
say I watched the hearing online and you
could certainly say at a minimum that
the commissioner was not eager to have
the audit and I don't know why it's a
public money it's a public program we
all pay for it we want it we want our
children in the program to be doing well
whether we agree with the policy or not
why not want a full audit why not put a
little daylight on it so that was
concerning and then yesterday I went to
the oversight committee meeting and uh
it came to light that the department has
been taking down from its website
reports about what where some of the
money is going in the audit in the uh
voucher program and reports about what
vendors are getting money and how much
they're getting the representative from
the doe explained that the reason for
that was because that information really
was brought up by the scholarship
organization they're the ones that
collected that information but it's been
online for a year and a half two years
why suddenly is it going offline and
it's nowhere else that the public can
find it at the
why not and so all of this raises
questions in my mind and I would hope in
yours it seems like this information
that's being obscured is not being
wanted why not why don't we want to have
a full picture of this program before we
even commit more money to it and that's
basically my question and I I feel that
the public relies on you all to
carefully Steward public funds and
choosing to expand it this program when
the department is seems to be hiding
information and not wanting it to be
very carefully looked at would be
irresponsible and it would undermine the
Public's trust in all of you and for
that reason I'm uh concerned about it
and since if I have a couple one more
minute I would say that I agree with the
idea of reducing the scholarship
organization's fee from 10% to 8% I
would suggest looking into doing the
same with the education tax credit uh
scholarship program because a lot of
these students overlap they're they're
get putting together data about the same
families it can't cost as
much per family you know when you when
you when you you get you get what I mean
I don't want to keep you from lunch I
hope you understand what I meant by that
thank you thank you very much uh
representative dry and then
representative
luckus thank you and thank you for
taking my question so I listened to your
testimony this morning in the Senate and
when you talked about um finding the
information from the scholarship
organization uh correct me if I'm wrong
I thought you said that information
could be gotten from the
scholarship organization yes it's not
posted anywhere what I'm saying the only
reason I got it was I kept looking on
the website for the updated report for
the year that ended last school you know
last school year last June of vendors
all we've ever seen publicly is the
first year we're in the we're almost at
the end of the third year so I kept
looking for it and it was never posted
so I finally emailed Kate Baker deur and
asked for it and she did provide it um
it said draft I said why does it say
draft and she said because it hasn't yet
I've sent it to the doe but they haven't
posted it yet and I want to make sure
they're fine with it it's still not
posted and it's not available so yes I
happen to know because I come here all
the time who to call when I want that
you can't get online and find it as far
as I can
tell yes okay so just to clarify it is
available it's just not available online
like it was last year because you said
differently I'm sorry I didn't mean that
it's not available I meant it's not it's
not publicly posted where the average
person could find it bya Google search
okay thank you thank you very much
representa
leus you had mentioned um in talking
about doing
the
audit um risk Etc and I was wondering if
you were aware that an a risk audit has
been done every year and they have
passed every year
it's just not the full
audit that has been completed yet but
the risk audit it has been done every
year if I what I'm the only audit I've
ever been able to find is the financial
audit of the entire New York City based
organization that has uh offices in 18
or 21 different states something like
that um that doesn't look specifically
at um are people care I don't as I read
that report
it doesn't look at things like um our
parents they didn't do like a random
sample of parents to make sure that the
money is actually being spent on what
it's supposed to be spent on or uh that
the various qualifications that people
have to have to get in that kind of
thing and that's what this legislative
that's why as I understand it why the
legislature wanted to have this audit to
get into finding those kinds of risks
that wasn't called a risk-based audit
that was a regular Financial audit done
for the large
organization
yes I was talking to the LBA when they
were here last week and they said they
had done a risk-based audit every year
and it had passed completely oh I'm not
aware of that and it's not maybe I'm
mistaken I'm sorry I'm not aware of it
when you look on the uh scholarship
organization's website that says
financials and then it says it has their
990 form and it has the financial audit
of the big company I've never been able
to find any other Audits and I actually
asked the doe if there were any other
Audits and they said here's the audit
and it was that big Financial one so
I've never seen any other audit and I've
looked okay maybe they would thank you
very much represent belard thank you Mr
chair thank you for being here to take
my question yeah I know the speaker is
not
ideal um you you were you mentioning in
the audit um and I know there's been
some controversy around what has
occurred and I'll admit that I'm not as
up to date as I want to be I have a bit
more to learn about what has occurred
around that um but but is it is it
accurate that some of the controversy
was surrounding certain requests for
information that were made that included
personally identifiable information for
either students or their families in the
EFA
program I really don't know I um I don't
know because I don't I don't think they
made public what the requests were I
know that the commissioner mentioned it
would make it wouldn't be right to go
and ask tutor Inc to give us all their
uh all the information about every
student but I doubt that's what I doubt
that that's what an auditor would be
asking I would suspect that they would
be asking for procedures that are in
place to make sure that all the
requirements in the law are being met
and you wouldn't need to know the names
and IDs of students to do that but I
don't know I I don't know what they were
asking for f questions from the
committee not seeing thank you very much
for your testimony and with that I have
no further pin card so I'm going to
close the hearing for
442 and we're going to take a yes before
before you break for L could you answer
proceed your question for me
please what's your question um I know
we're receiving Senate bills and at
least 10 of us on this table were very
concerned about seeing Senate Bill 499
come forward so I was checking the
docket to see what was going to come
forward um because it deals with
meals uh and I found out that from the
docket that you had waved it off um so
we're not going to see that we'll be
able to discuss that and I was just
curious I understand stand it's in your
prerogative to wave the bill right past
us I was just curious why that
occurred that was vacated to another
committee where they're dealing with
elderly Affairs in which we do not deal
with elderly Affairs and some of the
issues which are associated with HHS
there was a small partion relative to
education but when upon re reviewing it
and approved by the speaker it has now
gone to another committee it's more
appropriate well but for
yeah is did you wave it off to another
Comm the speaker because the doctor says
you did yes I asked that it be vacated
okay so my only point for that reason
the the first paragraph the first
portion in that bill dealt with student
breakfast meals I understand that I
understand that and we never get to talk
about it okay Woodcock I'm not going to
discuss any further I just explained to
you that it was vacated for a purpose
that was other than what you're talking
about there are issues in that which
were belonged in another committee and
upon reviewing that with the clerk it
was seen that yes it should have gone to
another committee we have that happened
with bills periodically and we do vacant
them to the proper committee you can
testify and followed up with that
committee no I I I believe you you're
honest thank thank you very much and
what we're going to do is we're going to
take a caucus right now and both both
caucuses are going to meet right now and
then we're going to come back in about
quarter up sure y great
y we
may
e
e e
finished discussing prior to in a
hearing and I'm gonna hand the Gabel off
to representative
peternell than G you go ahead and pound
to the C all you want right we're going
to
have an executive session on House Bill
442 relative to sorry Senate Bill 442
relative to student
eligibility for education Freedom
accounts and the scholarship
organizations's costs of administering
the program extending phase out grants
for Education Freedom accounts and
revising the definitions of average
daily membership in attendance and
average daily membership in residents
and with that I call on chairman lad to
make a motion yes thank you very much
representa I'd make the motion of itl
Sir would either of you like to comment
or sorry comment from the maker of the
motion yes we have dealt with this issue
we have submitted a bill to to the
Senate this time so I think there's no
further need for
discussion thank you
I
so so the motion the motion was made no
I'm looking rep and
dry I know I'm just I'm like I do I do I
do have a concern I I do have a com yeah
representative Miler I think my second
is based upon the issue of not a need to
expand the program to its current level
uh as I mentioned in the testimony of
Senator Lang I'm concerned about the
um the overspending of it uh I'm
concerned about the department not uh
projecting appropriately for their
budget so we have some sense of what the
guideline is and it's for those reasons
that I think uh moving it from 350 to
400 is inappropriate
any other comments from the
committee it's uh
442 going to slow down a little bit
later Kat
up I
can was motion be by lad and second by
Miler the motion was itl
let just let Kate Katie know when you're
ready any other subs Mary's no longer a
sub you are are she's
full-time
okay yeah yeah okay okay thank you will
the clerk please call the vote motion is
itl start with
all right uh representative
Pell
yes representative leus yes
representative beler yes representative
dry yes representative Noble yes
representative
Terry yes representative Miler yes
representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes representative
luno yes representative Heath yes
representative Woodcock yes
representative Hall yes representative
Bon yes representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes chairman lad
yes 17 yays and three not
voting yeah would it would be Z 17 y
zero Nays three three AB
three yeah we're good okay for consent
thank
you and we close out the executive
session on Senate Bill
442 thank you very much now getting back
to what we have coming up for there's a
subcommittee meeting at 1:00 obviously
we're going to have to break for lunch
um that bill is dealing with the 6306
rules the component we talked about the
that
subcommittee and I do have a couple
concerns and questions uh so I
excuse me the pbass yes yeah yeah yeah
yeah
so
um it's a it's a subcommittee
um do who are the ones we're going to be
on that right now it's
it's yeah and me
c do you want to meet today or do you
want to do it on a different day are you
good still doing it or I
don't
yeah they they could not make it today
that was part of the issue too they
can't they couldn't make it
today for for the rest of the folks here
we're we're done that we're just talking
about whether we're going to go forward
with the subcommittee meeting today or
not
he we're we're going to cancel that
meeting that was scheduled for this
afternoon and we'll pick it up at
another time thank
you
e
e e